en este vídeo voy a hablar del sistema
nervioso autónomo que es parte de todo
el sistema nervioso
esta es una clasificación funcional del
sistema nervioso no una división
estructural como la del sistema nervioso
central y el sistema nervioso periférico
el sistema nervioso autónomo consta de
neuronas y gerentes en el sistema
nervioso periférico que realizan
funciones específicas estas neuronas
diferentes controlan tres tipos de
células el primero son las células de
músculo suave que se encuentran en todo
tipo de estructuras del cuerpo como por
ejemplo alrededor de los vasos
sanguíneos también controlan el músculo
cardíaco que conforman el tejido del
corazón estos tipos de tejidos
musculares son diferentes de los
músculos esqueléticos que están unidos a
todo el esqueleto y que permiten el
movimiento pues estos son controlados
por otras neuronas diferentes del
sistema nervioso periférico son
controladas por neuronas motoras menores
no autónomas y lo último que controlan
las células autónomas son las células
glandulares
sistema nervioso autónomo se llama así
porque controla todas estas cosas sin
necesidad de la conciencia o la voluntad
el sistema nervioso autónomo se divide
en dos subsistemas voy a dibujar dos
flechas aquí este es el sistema nervioso
simpático que es una parte importante
del sistema nervioso autónomo y
abreviados sistema nervioso simpático
como sn ese y la otra gran parte del
sistema nervioso autónomo es el sistema
nervioso parasimpático que abre veamos
cómo snp existen muchas diferencias
entre estas dos partes del sistema
nervioso autónomo que mencionaremos en
este vídeo introductorio la primera
diferencia está en donde comienzan en el
sistema nervioso central el sistema
nervioso simpático comienza a la mitad
de la médula espinal voy a dibujar
algunos o más aquí toma uno de ellos y
le dibujó un axón corto de la primera
neurona que sale del sistema nervioso
central y que va a ser sinapsis con una
segunda neurona en un ganglio que está
cerca de la primera neurona la segunda
neurona
a enviar una acción más largo para
llegar a la célula objetivo aquí
dibujamos una o mayúscula para
representar la célula objetivo con la
que hará sinapsis
esta célula objetivo puede ser una
célula de músculo suave una célula de
músculo cardíaco o una célula glandular
aquí hay un diagrama de todo el sistema
nervioso autónomo vemos la parte media
de la médula espinal en donde comienzan
las primeras neuronas del sistema
simpático y luego tienen una acción
pequeño con el que hacen sinapsis en un
ganglio muy cercano a la columna aquí
hay un conjunto de ganglios y por acá
hay otros ganglios pero todos tienden a
estar muy cerca de la médula espinal
todos estos ganglios están entrelazados
y forman una cadena que llamamos la
cadena simpática aquí hay otro diagrama
sobre lo mismo aquí vemos que en la
parte de enmedio de la médula espinal
salen los primeros axones luego hacen
sinapsis en un ganglio cercano a la
médula y también vemos varios de estos
ganglios enlazados como una cadena
después vemos la segunda neurona que
envía un axón largo que hará sinapsis
con las
el objetivo en cualquier tejido que
contenga células de músculo suave
células de músculo cardíaco o células
glandulares por otra parte el sistema
nervioso parasimpático tiene sus
primeras neuronas en una parte diferente
del sistema nervioso central comienzan
aquí en el tronco encefálico o comienzan
en la parte de abajo de la médula
espinal
la primera neurona envía un axón largo
para hacer sinapsis con la segunda
neurona en un ganglio alejado de la
primera y la segunda neurona normalmente
envía un axón corto para hacer sinapsis
con la célula objetivo aquí dibujo otra
o mayúscula para indicar que es una
célula objetivo este diagrama también
muestra esto las primeras neuronas del
sistema nervioso parasimpático están
aquí arriba en el tronco encefálico o
hasta abajo de la médula espinal también
muestra el axón largo de la primera
neurona que alcanza un ganglio alejado
de la zona de la primera neurona y envía
un axón corto que hace sinapsis con la
célula objetivo aquí hay otro diagrama
que muestra lo mismo las primeras
neuronas
que están en el tronco encefálico o que
salen de la parte de abajo de la médula
espinal estos primeros axones largos
llegan a ganglios alejados de la primera
soma y luego la segunda neurona envía un
axón corto hacia la célula objetivo las
semejanzas entre la estructura de las
diferentes partes del sistema nervioso
autónomo consiste en por lo general en
una cadena de dos neuronas que conectan
el sistema nervioso central con la
célula objetivo la diferencia consiste
en donde se encuentra el inicio de la
primera neurona y en sí el primer acción
es largo y el segundo corto o si el
primer acción es corto y el segundo
largo pero más importante que las
diferencias estructurales entre las
diferentes partes del sistema nervioso
autónomo son las diferencias funcionales
y estas neuronas hacen tantas cosas
diferentes en tantos tejidos diferentes
en el cuerpo que es un poco difícil
hablar de esto en general hay un par de
frases que nos pueden ayudar a recordar
las distintas cosas que hacen estas
partes del sistema nervioso autónomo
para el sistema nervioso simpático la
frase
huir o pelear cuando se activa el
sistema nervioso simpático ocasiona
muchos cambios en el cuerpo que lo
preparan ya sea para pelear o para huir
es decir que prepara al cuerpo para
lidiar con situaciones peligrosas lo voy
a escribir en color rojo para indicar
que me refiero al sistema nervioso
simpático por otro lado el sistema
nervioso parasimpático lo voy a señalar
con un color verde relajante pues su
frase es descansar y digerir cuando este
sistema se activa ocasiona muchos
cambios en el cuerpo que son importantes
para la homeostasis y el mantenimiento
del cuerpo en situaciones que no son
amenazantes veamos algunos ejemplos de
ciertos tejidos que tienen respuestas
diferentes para que se den cuenta de a
qué se refiere esto primero veamos el
sistema gastrointestinal el estómago y
los intestinos tanto el sistema
simpático como el sistema parasimpático
afectan muchas funciones del sistema
gastrointestinal una de ellas es el
flujo sanguíneo que va a los intestinos
porque la cantidad de sangre que llega
al intestino juega un gran papel en que
tanta digestión puede hacer y esto
también afecta a la cantidad de sangre
que llega a otras partes del cuerpo
cuando se activa el sistema nervioso
simpático durante alguna situación de
huir o pelear disminuye el flujo de
sangre a los intestinos que se desvía a
los músculos esqueléticos para que los
músculos de todo el cuerpo nos ayuden a
lidiar con la situación de peligro ya
que las situaciones de peligro no son el
momento para digerir comida sino para
moverse por lo que disminuye el flujo de
los intestinos y se desvía hacia los
músculos esqueléticos bien mientras que
la mayor parte del tiempo cuando no
estamos en situaciones de peligro y es
momento de relajarse y descansar el
sistema nervioso parasimpático se activa
incrementando el flujo sanguíneo a los
intestinos desvía el flujo sanguíneo de
los músculos esqueléticos porque ahora
el cuerpo no está en una situación de
peligro por lo que ahora puede descansar
y digerir por eso el flujo sanguíneo va
hacia los intestinos para incrementar la
habilidad
alimentos ahora veamos cómo se afecta el
corazón cuando se activa el sistema
simpático y el parasimpático veamos el
gasto cardíaco o qué tanta sangre bombea
el corazón en cierta unidad de tiempo
cuando se activa el sistema nervioso
simpático el gasto cardíaco aumenta el
corazón bombea más rápido y más fuerte y
envía más sangre a lugares como el
músculo esquelético además de desviar el
flujo sanguíneo de los intestinos hacia
los músculos esqueléticos el corazón
aumenta su gasto para que les llegue a
estos aún más sangre cuando se activa el
sistema nervioso parasimpático disminuye
el gasto cardíaco por lo que el corazón
late más despacio y con menos fuerza
trabaja menos porque no se necesita más
flujo sanguíneo para que los músculos se
muevan así que se queda en un nivel
básico que es suficiente para las
actividades que involucran descansar y
digerir estos ejemplos del flujo
sanguíneo involucran la actividad de los
músculos suaves que rodean a los vasos
sanguíneos y determinan hacia dónde va a
ir la sangre
involucran al músculo cardíaco porque
este músculo constituye al corazón y
cuando pensamos en las células
glandulares hay varias glándulas que son
controladas por el sistema nervioso
autónomo y tienden a ser activadas de
forma diferente en distintos momentos un
tipo de glándula que se activa en
situaciones de pelear o huir cuando
entra en acción el sistema nervioso
simpático son las glándulas sudoríparas
que se encuentran en la piel son
activadas para secretar sudor lo que
refresca al cuerpo y así incrementa su
habilidad de moverse más rápido y más
lejos en cambio las glándulas que se
activan cuando el sistema parasimpático
entra en acción
incluyen a las glándulas salivales que
producen saliva en la boca porque la
saliva es muy útil para la digestión y
es parte de varias actividades que
ocurren para ayudarnos a digerir comida
estas frases son muy útiles cuando trato
de recordar cómo afecta el sistema
nervioso autónomo a los diferentes
tejidos del cuerpo durante situaciones
distintas porque como lo vimos en estos
ejemplos la mayoría de las cosas que
hacen
tema nervioso simpático cuando se activa
aumenta las habilidades del cuerpo para
transformar la energía almacenada en
movimiento para tratar con situaciones
peligrosas cómo mover la sangre del
intestino a los músculos esqueléticos y
aumentar la cantidad de sangre que
bombea el corazón así como incrementar
la producción de sudor de las glándulas
sudoríparas para que el cuerpo se
mantenga fresco cuando está en
movimiento durante la situación
peligrosa mientras que todas las cosas
que hace el sistema parasimpático tienen
sentido en situaciones donde no hay
peligro y queremos conservar y almacenar
energía como desviar sangre de los
músculos esqueléticos a los intestinos
para aumentar la digestión así como
disminuir el ritmo y el gasto cardíaco
para conservar energía e incrementar la
producción de saliva de las glándulas
salivales para ayudar con la digestión
también pero el sistema nervioso
autónomo afecta a muchas estructuras más
y tiene muchas más funciones de las que
puedo mencionar en este vídeo
introductorio por ejemplo el sistema
nervioso autónomo tiene que ver con el
cambio del tamaño de las pupilas
con las respuestas sexuales y con la
secreción de muchas otras glándulas y
debido a que realiza tantas cosas
diferentes me parece mejor no cubrir las
todas de una sola vez sino aprender
sobre estas cosas conforme veamos cada
sistema orgánico individual ya que cada
sistema orgánico va a tener neuronas
autónomas que llegan a él y afectan el
funcionamiento de este sistema orgánico